il était une fois
un garçon qui aime est une fille
ensemble ils inventaient des milliers de
cheveux
il lui promet qu'il n'aimerait jamais au
que notre fille et aussi longtemps
qu'ils vivent les eaux
c'est sûr que tu passes et or quand elle
tue à qousseir décret louis ou non fait
60 ans il ya prescription
et quand je suis très heureux mais qui
me dérange c'est que toi que je bouge
les adversaires il m'a pas calculé que
toute la soirée des compagnies que je
préfère qu'on reste amis
tomita qui se disent que je suis facile
histoire d'amour ça dure par regarde
autour de toi si tu l'aimais ayant tu
dois laisser sont allés les allemands
sont à 300 kilomètres ni si les eaux je
t'épouserais à new york
promets moi que tu viendras je te jeu
pro fait qu'une amour ça existe que dans
les livres
c'est totalement faux mais rimouski a
vraiment essayé
l'amour est vrai
j'ai cru
s'il te plaît
tu aimes vraiment mais ça m'étonnerait
qu'elle te le disent parce qu'elle est
fière
un jour tu la rejoindra